I go do you condemn Israel for killing
innocent Palestinian kids she goes I
don't believe they're innocent because
you can see how his attitude is and his
actual beliefs from the Torah and talmud
compared to nationalist Zionist who he
was just talking to and she was clearly
saying oh I don't believe Palestinian
kids are innocent
civilians brothers and sisters just
imagine for a second that you give 1010
in donation and that is used to buy food
or bricks or whatever to help the people
in Gaza but then just imagine this
amazing de that you want to do but we
turn it into a moneymaking machine how
the W is exactly that they take your
money and the money that we are going to
put in in this W this building and every
single time the money generated from
that W that building is going to go to
our Palestinian brothers and sisters for
the next 20 30 40 50 60 100 150 years
and this will be a form of
true I myself will be donating for that
inshah click the link below and donate
may Allah subhana bless and preserve you
guys I repeat again you have been
massacring yes it is okay themselves
then look look look look look look guys
guys guys guys guys guys guys look at
what he's saying he's saying they are
killing their themselves responsible
listen to me do you not have do you have
children yes do you have no at way of
Shame you are a father I have three
daughters you are a Shameless man you
are a Shameless man let me tell you why
let me tell you why you have kids how
old are your kids if you don't mind me
asking 12 and 10 12 and are they're even
here I didn't even know that if I saw
anyone listen one second you are pro
Israeli correct if I saw anyone going
close to your kids to harm them I would
physically harm them myself okay well I
don't don't I
would number one how as a father your
daughters are here I've got three
daughters I've got a 6-year-old I've got
a 2-year-old and I've got a 5 Monon old
yeah
heal if Israel doesn't exist yes they
would be if because if I was a
Palestinian living in Palestine my kids
would be Massac pause pause pause pause
pause pause if Israel doesn't exist are
you calling for are you are you calling
yes or no question are you calling for
the eradication and the end of the state
of Israel I am calling the eradication I
repeat again I'm call the genocide call
here you or me who's genocide because
they kill innocent people he thinks I'm
asking for the same I am against a state
repeat again I am against I am against a
state not individual did I ever say to
you did I ever say to you I want
innocent people harmed you can't talk to
do you know why you're saying that
because because your government kills
innocent people you think I'm doing the
same I would never ever ask for any
Jewish or Zionist or any Muslim or
non-muslim for that matter to be harmed
I'm seeing the state in itself and by
the way there are the Jewish Zion Jewish
people in Israel who want Netanyahu out
of uh Power so
demy do they want a genocide against are
they self Jew are they self-hating Jews
are they self-hating Jews am I a
self-hating Englishman for thank you so
I'm asking you a question why do you not
condemn the killing of people who are
killing children at your daughter's age
can I now answer please because I do not
believe I genuinely do not believe I
think it is fake news that Israel is
indiscriminately bombing innocent
civilians I think Israel does everything
it can everything in its power to avoid
and to limit the damage the um the innoc
for example for example for example they
drop leaflets fers everywhere they make
announcements on radio they phone call
people and speak to them in Arabic how
romantic they they announce in advance
how romantic they announce in advance we
believe there is a Hamas tunnel or Hamas
cell in your building please can you go
and remove all the people in your
building and then they're on the firm
with these people and they say is
everyone gone now we're going to buom
which other army in the world British
American which other army in the world
announces hey by the way we're coming in
an hour or two or three we're warning
you we're about to come and bomb you
please leave first it's ridiculous all
right no problem let's let's go let's go
let's go let's go with the analogy yeah
if they if they have listen brother so
if this is them being look look guys
they've killed 27,000 civilians if this
is
them the source is clear the source is
clear s is clear no no let me let me let
me get this right let me get this right
Palestinians one second
no no no yeah I know 22,000 now the the
numbers are increasing let me guess
Palestinians are killing themselves yeah
I'm sure they are come on anyways
anyways anyways anyway now now if if
indirectly there you go you can't make
this up now guys
if the most Humane army in the
world my friend my friend my friend look
at this look
look you are a liar you are a liar that
was exposed you're a liar that was
exposed not only that a spokesman a
spokesman a spokesman for Israel he made
a tweet and he said we we attacked guess
what guess what he deleted his tweet and
we haven't heard from him ever since
number one number two number two now if
you're telling me if you're telling me
Israel the most human army in the world
has called them and gave leaflets out
can you imagine the amount of civilians
would have been killed if they didn't do
that if 27,000 people have been killed
check this out check this out check this
out yeah 7,000 people have been killed
and with them telling them by the way
we're going to check this is that me
saying to you I'm taking over your house
just to let you know I'm going to bomb
you one second one second one second can
you imagine me as a Muslim I go I go to
my friend what's your name Harry Harry I
go Harry listen I'm about to blow your
house up yeah listen can you leave with
you and the kids and family okay thank
you bye-bye and and then one second one
second one second one second one second
no you missone part the I'm about to
your house up there are there are
terrorists underneath your building all
right good good okay there Che I'm
running check this out there are
terrorist in your house in your building
I'm going to blow it up here I'm running
away as fast as I can you cannot make
this up hello I'm about to blow your
family up can you leave
okay I have condemned I condemn I
condemn Hamas Israel America anyone that
kills civilians do you condemn Israel I
condemn anybody who indiscriminately
kills innocent civilians Hamas for the
started I don't believe Israel is
indiscriminate look at this look at this
look at this and I am the terrorist you
are a terrorist supporter you are a
terrorist supporter you you know what
you've got two you've got two daughters
are 10 seconds in 10 seconds why am I
terrorist because you do not condemn the
state Terror that's been carried out by
Israel against the PES no I don't accept
that there is do you condemn Israel look
look at that camera no I do not condemn
Israel I do not because I do not accept
that they are committing terrorism can
we get closer to this man's face I do
not condemn Israel because I do not AC
you are a terrorist can I you are a
terrorist suppor until you bring me
evidence until you bring me evidence I
condemn Hamas namas I condemn Israel
America anybody that K Inn people now do
you come in Israel do you come Israel no
you guys went into Israel and killed
inent people they don't care do you have
kids do you have kids do you have kids
no you have kids do you have any nieces
yes okay what why if somebody killed
them for what reason like if what
happened for no reason you no reason for
no reason no no no no no no they went
and killed them how how would you feel I
would feel terrible why because they're
getting murder okay so do you condemn
Israel I condemn Israel with the Right
facts and knowing exactly exctly do you
believe do you accept that Israel killed
innocent Palestinian children I don't
think they're innocent whoa that's the
thing is I don't think they're innocent
I think that's firstly firstly firstly
thank you for your honesty I'll repeat
again I go do you condemn Israel for
killing innocent Palestinian kids she
goes I don't believe they're innocent
you don't believe they're innocent a
5-year-old Child Is Not Innocent come on
don't be shy I'm saying I don't I think
that they're being put in a position
that they're that they're not don't
change your tone you said I don't
believe they're innocent said you are a
terrorist I'm a terrorist you are a
terrorist I shame on you I would you are
as good as going the one who is silent
is a silent devil shame on you I went in
and killed shame on you nieces jabby
please guys you're not making my please
you have nieces and you are here saying
do you know what she said she said
Palestinian kids are not innocent do you
have no shame I don't have a lot of
Shame now shame on you if I didn't have
shame I would spit let me tell if I
didn't have a shame I swear to God you I
have some Integrity you are a Shameless
woman you are a terrist supervisor and I
hope I hope God I hope God deals with
you and I hope and I hope and I hope
that your nieces I hope any child in
your family is never harmed you are a
sick individual you're a sicko you shame
on you sicko flipping sicko she and this
is what they were saying she goes
Palestinian kids are not innocent you
can't make this up context look I said
context what's the context the context
is is that Hamas is not putting them in
hospitals or places that the Israel is
ADV advance where's the evidence the IDF
IDF IDF is
evidence shame on you so what would you
say now would you like what's happening
with Israel do you believe it is correct
what they are doing like in the sense
where because I see some rabbis quoting
amalekites yeah killing men women
children but Zionism I don't believe
Zionism I believe some of them are
atheist zist yes that's true is there no
difference between Zionism and Judaism
there is yeah exactly so do you you what
would you say like what's your stance on
Israel now as a state what they're doing
regarding the war the war the occupation
the aparti the
genocide um the occupation of of of the
West Bank or or generally Israel all of
Palestine they wanted the land you know
it's like they wanted to be like all the
nations like no just have a land to a
home a home for the Jews they call it a
home yeah so um but but religiously is
that according to the Torah and the T no
no it's not it's against okay so it's
against and also the Messiah will not
come until that state is abolished yes
that what it says so then would I be
correct to say as a true Jew you would
want that state to not exist so the
Messiah comes religiously yes okay so
that's so that's interesting okay okay I
just want to know this cuz I'm trying to
get the Dynamics and understand there
okay so let's say Palestine yeah
Palestine was there if the Jews live
together with the Palestinians and the
Christians and no persecutions yeah okay
what does that mean by the way goam goam
means Gentiles oh okay interesting so
for example if the Jews lived in the
Palestinian lands which they did yes if
it's not on homeland let's say it's
Palestine but the Jews live with the
Palestinians no problem at all mhm is
that the
solution they wanted the government okay
so if they according to Judaism would
you not say that them living in the
Palestines cuz number one they want the
Messiah to come number two they wants
the Messiah to come je um not the
Zionist because if you believe in that's
the here here's the main point here
because the zionists do not believe in
Messiah that's why so when will we have
the Homeland when will you have a land
never because they do not believe in
Messiah so why not take it now good so
they are nationalists yeah National so
we got nationalism and real Jews the
real Jews like yourself would have no
problem living with the Palestinians
because it serves them how number one
they have a land they live under they
are not persecuted because they've lived
there for a very long time it's a holy
land a it's not just very holy a holy
land to us and you yeah very holy so we
all can have an agreement that it's a
holy land we live in peace because the
Palestinians never persecuted the Jews
yeah yeah so I think for a real Jew if
I'm not mistaken it works for you guys
to live in Palestine as their land live
together in peace as they did for
centuries cuz it works for you in how
number one you stick into the Torah and
number three that will that will allow
you to wait for the Messiah to come
there because there's no government yeah
did you get it he could have come he
could have come exactly so the fact that
Israel the Zionist National have started
the
state the Messiah is not going to come
he works against you it works against
yeah so there won't be a s Temple if if
if it continues like this yeah it's very
sad but do you like you condemn what
Israel is doing by killing innocent men
women and children
discriminating yes I think civilians
shouldn't be killed even if it's a war
it's civilians should be protected do
you see that's very interesting cuz I
was speaking to another Jewish person
and he was refusing to condemn Israel
and he some of them was saying
Palestinians are they tiing They're Not
Innocent the kids the children show are
Innocent but you see it's the difference
you see guys it's very important look at
what he's saying La Ellie and look at
what the Zionist I spoke to about so
when people come and talk about
anti-Semitism I mean I I'll be honest
with you some people call it as um Tak
whatever it's called that's what she has
yeah just just saying that's I'm not
trying to say in a negative way I have
no problem with you as an individual My
Religion doesn't have a problem with you
as an individual you can live under
Islamic Rule and you have lived in
Islamic Rule and Muslims have protected
yes has there been instances where
Muslims have persecuted the Jews yes but
majority 95% of the time no and the
point is very interesting because how
could it be anti-Semitism when my
religion yes it talks about the children
of Israel yes how they went against God
how they went against Moses yeah we talk
about that God talks about how we punish
them and doesn't it say in your book
that God Almighty also punish the Jews
before breaking the Covenant uh which
Covenant like for example when they get
went against God's covenant hasn't
hasn't God Almighty punished them yeah
there was punishment good good so there
you go does that mean now you're
anti-semitic against yourself no God
punished those who didn't go against
their commandment and the same with us
Muslims so this anti-Semitism nonsense
is clear because you can see how his
attitude is and his actual beliefs from
the Torah and talm compared to
nationalist Zionist who he was just
talking to and she was clearly saying oh
I don't believe Palestinian kids are
innocent civilians